.
Ando reist nach 23 Jahren zum ersten
Mal wieder in seine Heimat Armenien.
Nach so langer Zeit
wieder hier zu sein ist ... schön.
Ja.
Susan will in Amerika
ihre Wurzeln finden
und ihren Vater besser kennenlernen.
Ich habe eine Mankobeziehung
zu meinem Vater.
Ich vermisse ihn sehr.
Und ihn nicht zu haben
hat mich sehr geprägt.
Und Sairah wagt in Indien
einen letzten Versuch,
ihre leibliche Mutter zu finden.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Das ist eine Reise
zurück zu den Wurzeln.
Die Reise in "Meine fremde Heimat".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Sairah ist schon seit ein paar Tagen
mit ihrer Freundin Natalia
in Kalkutta.
Als Dreijährige
wurde sie von Schweizern adoptiert.
Jetzt will sie
ihre leibliche Mutter finden.
Sie war auf der Gemeinde,
bei Adoptionsagenturen
und in Waisenhäusern -
alles ohne Erfolg.
Oh, schau mal.
- Wow.
Aber Sairah sucht auf dieser Reise
nicht nur ihre Wurzeln,
sondern möchte auch die Kultur
ihrer fremden Heimat
kennenlernen und mitnehmen.
* Englisch *
Das schöne Blau.
- Yes, why not?
Wow, wow.
Oh.
Vielleicht fühle ich mich
dann eher als Inderin.
Mehr zu Indien hingezogen
als zu Europa.
Ja.
Ich bin noch etwas von den
vielen schönen Farben überfordert.
Was möchte ich gerne?
(Mann) This colour is
looking better than that one
because the colour of the sari ...
Ich denke, das würde mir
überhaupt nicht stehen.
Man braucht dafür
die dunkle Hautfarbe.
Man braucht die Anmut
dieser Frauen hier.
Ich sehe es enorm gern.
Ja, es ist wirklich edel.
Lässig.
- Super.
Schön.
* Hupen *
* Indische Klänge *
Sairah erlebte in den letzten Tagen
viele Rückschläge.
Jede Spur verlief im Sand.
Trotzdem will sie die Reise geniessen
und den indischen Alltag erleben.
Dazu gehören auch Rikschas.
Allein in Kalkutta
gibt es Zehntausende davon.
Aber es ist ...
- Abfallentsorgung.
Hier ist es ordentlicher
als an vielen Orten.
Jöh, sie durchsucht auch den Abfall.
Wir gehen nun zum Medium.
- Also zum Guru.
In Richtung ... Ja.
Zum spirituellen Kontakt.
Genau.
Ich bin mir
immer noch nicht sicher,
ob ich mit dir komme oder nicht.
Ja, das kannst du
vor Ort entscheiden.
Bevor wir reingehen.
- Okay.
Wenn alles Menschenmögliche
nichts bringt,
hilft vielleicht das Universum.
Das Treffen mit dem Guru
ist Sairahs letzte Hoffnung.
Am Flughafen in Jerewan
wird jemand sehnsüchtig erwartet.
Ando landet nach 23 Jahren
zum ersten Mal wieder in Armenien.
Seine Freundin Giada begleitet ihn
auf der Reise in die fremde Heimat.
Andos Onkel und sein Cousin
holen die beiden ab.
Es ist ein schönes Gefühl.
Ich bin noch nicht
ganz klar im Kopf,
aber es ist wahnsinnig,
nach 23 Jahren zurück zu sein.
Ando war sieben, als seine Familie
aus der Armut Armeniens
geflüchtet ist.
Nach ein paar Jahren in der Schweiz
trennten sich seine Eltern.
Der Vater
musste zurück nach Armenien.
Dort starb er vor vier Jahren.
Ando hat viele Verwandte,
die er besuchen möchte.
Es ist gesperrt, weil sie
anscheinend die Strasse machen.
* Er spricht armenisch. *
Er versucht zu umfahren.
Du siehst nicht wer fährt.
Willkommen in Armenien.
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Über Lautsprecher.
In der Schweiz
würden wir gleich in U-Haft kommen.
* Orientalisch anmutende Musik *
Das ist das Haus von Onkel Arsen.
Er ist der Bruder von Andos Vater.
- Willkommen.
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
* Emotionale Musik *
Anstossen, viel Glück wünschen,
damit man Erfolg im Leben
und Gesundheit hat.
* Sie spricht armenisch. *
Alles Positive.
Sie sagte zudem,
ich hätte eine hübsche Freundin.
Ich trinke keinen Alkohol,
aber das ist es mir wert.
Ich bin in Armenien.
Ich muss das probieren.
Sie habe das auch gemacht.
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
Du merkst es gar nicht.
Es ist sehr lecker, sehr süss.
Ando ist Profiboxer
und sehr streng mit sich selber.
Aber den Begrüssungsschnaps
darf er nicht ausschlagen.
Es ist sehr typisch armenisch
eingerichtet.
Es kommen alte Erinnerungen hoch.
Und wirklich ...
Onkel Arsen nimmt Ando
auf wie seinen eigenen Sohn.
* Sanfte, melancholische Musik *
Sairah spürt seit Jahren
die Energie von Familienmitgliedern.
Darum war sie schon in der Schweiz
bei einem Medium.
Das prophezeite ihr, dass sie in
Indien eine grosse Familie habe
und die Suche
erfolgreich verlaufen würde.
Ich möchte ihr jetzt
diesen Raum lassen.
Es ist ihr Entscheid.
Ich habe eine andere
Glaubenseinstellung als sie.
Ich möchte sie freilassen,
damit sie diesen Raum einnehmen
und ihren Weg gehen kann. Genau.
Der Weg führt sie am Tag
vor der Heimreise zu einem Guru,
einem spirituellen Meister,
der angeblich alles weiss.
* Sanfte, mysteriöse Musik
mit weiblichen Gesangsstimmen *
(Englisch)
* Spannungsgeladene,
meditative Musik *
* Zehrende, melancholische Musik *
Im Moment ...
muss ich erst alles verarbeiten.
Und vielleicht ... Ich weiss
im Moment nicht, wie's weitergeht.
Ja.
* Bedrückende Musik *
Wie ist es dir ergangen?
Magst du erzählen?
Ich habe
sehr viel Neues ... erfahren.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich meine Zeit brauche,
um das zu verarbeiten.
Es hat dich sehr aufgewühlt.
Nicht aufgewühlt ...
... aber ...
... es hat mich
ein bisschen traurig gemacht.
Weil es
keine guten Neuigkeiten waren?
Ich möchte im Moment
alles für mich behalten. - Ja.
Ich habe in dieser Zeit
ganz fest an dich gedacht.
Und ich habe mich dafür bedankt,
dass es dich gibt.
Und du bist wunderbar ...
und geliebt.
Gott und Jesus kennen deinen Weg.
Und sie werden dir beistehen
mit oder ohne Guru oder Medium.
Du wirst deinen Weg machen.
Ja.
* Melancholische Musik *
Einen Weg, der Sairah
morgen zurück in die Schweiz führt.
Sie fand zwar Antworten
auf ihre Fragen,
aber nicht die erhofften.
Und wer weiss - vielleicht
hat sich der Guru getäuscht,
und es gibt doch noch irgendwo
Verwandte.
* Die Musik verklingt langsam. *
Jerewan am nächsten Morgen.
Ando und Giada
sind früh auf den Beinen.
In Armeniens Hauptstadt
leben gut 1 Mio. Menschen.
Fast ein Vierteljahrhundert war Ando
nicht mehr im Land seiner Eltern.
Er staunt wie ein Tourist.
Wahnsinn!
Ich muss das festhalten.
Alle schauen zu.
- So schön.
Wahnsinn.
Vor 23 Jahren - das ist so alt
wie sie - war ich zuletzt hier.
Und ...
Es ist sehr aufregend.
Es ist ein unbeschreibliches Gefühl,
wieder zurück zu sein.
Es ist unglaublich schön.
* Rasante Musik *
Das sind unsere Nationalfrüchte:
Granatapfel.
Ando und Giada
sind seit fünf Jahren ein Paar.
Sie verreisen zum ersten Mal
zusammen so weit weg.
Warte!
Hier gibt's keine Ampel.
Vor dem Verkehr
habe ich grossen Respekt.
Sie fahren, wie sie wollen.
Es gibt keine Regeln.
- Keine Regeln.
Zu Hause in der Schweiz hat Ando
den Bezug zu seinen Wurzeln
in Armenien verloren.
Er hat den Kontakt zur Mutter
und den beiden Brüdern abgebrochen,
weil sie nicht verstanden haben,
warum ihm sein Traum, Profiboxer,
wichtiger war ist alles andere.
Ando entdeckt seine fremde Heimat
auf dieser Reise ganz neu.
Giada, willkommen in meiner Heimat.
Es ist schön hier.
Armenien liegt im Kaukasus-Gebirge
und grenzt an Georgien,
Aserbaidschan,
die Türkei und den Iran.
Ein Drittel der Einwohner
lebt in Jerewan,
der jungen und modernen Hauptstadt.
* Anschwellende
elektrisierende Musik *
Vom Zentrum sind es nur
wenige Minuten zu Fuss bis ins Grüne.
Sie baden trotz Badeverbot,
oder wie?
Wo steht das?
- Dort oben.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
In Armenien gibt es nicht
viele öffentliche Schwimmbäder.
Darum schwimmen die Menschen ...
- Es ist schön.
... im Fluss. Auch wir.
Er boxt.
Mit Autoreifen?
(Armenisch)
Cool, das ist noch Old-School-Gym.
Das ist absolut klasse.
Das gibt's in der Schweiz nicht.
Cool.
Ando ist Schweizermeister
im Superleichtgewicht.
Für ihn gibt es
keinen Tag ohne Training.
Direkt an der Strasse.
Das gibt's nur in Jerewan.
* Er stöhnt. *
Also ...
Hey, das ist aber megaschwer.
Liebe Giada, dein Personal Trainer
hat es richtig eingestellt.
Nein, nein.
Ist das gut?
- Sehr gut.
Alle schauen zu.
Das Outdoor-Gym gehört
zum unbeschwerten Bild von Jerewan.
Die Stadt hat aber auch
eine andere Seite.
Diese will Ando
seiner Freundin zeigen.
Zurück in der Schweiz in Glarus.
Die einen fühlen sich
zwischen den mächtigen Bergen
des Glarnerlands geborgen,
den anderen
wird es im Tal oft zu eng.
Zu letzteren
gehört auch Susan Stauffacher.
Sie wurde in den USA geboren und
hat Sehnsucht nach ihrem Geburtsland
und nach ihrem Vater
und ihren Halbschwestern.
Ich male ein Bild
für Dad und die Schwestern.
Es ist abstrakt.
Es ist erst am Entstehen.
Ich habe keine feste Vorstellung,
was es wird.
Als ich ...
... eineinhalbjährig war ...
... gingen meine Mutter und ich
zurück in die Schweiz.
Er ist geblieben, er ist Amerikaner.
Das war eine Trennung, bei der ich
einfach auch getrennt wurde.
Von ihm.
Ich habe eine Mankobeziehung
zu meinem Vater.
Ich vermisse ihn sehr.
Und ihn nicht zu haben
hat mich sehr geprägt.
Ich möchte ihn einfach kennenlernen
und auch einmal seine Seite hören.
Mich interessiert,
wie alles gekommen ist.
Aber ... Ich möchte ihn
auch im Jetzt kennenlernen.
Als erwachsene Frau.
Und meine Schwestern,
die erwachsen sind.
Eine ist noch jung, aber ja.
Susans Vater
wohnt an der Ostküste der USA
und ist zum zweiten Mal verheiratet.
Ihre Halbschwestern kennt Susan kaum.
Mit der jüngeren, Emily,
hat sie zu skypen angefangen.
Persönlich getroffen
haben sie sich noch nie.
(Englisch)
Emily ist 20.
Susan hat sie und ihre Schwester
Melissa auf Facebook gefunden.
Bye.
Sie habe ich noch nie live gesehen.
Ich freue mich herauszufinden,
wie sie ticken.
Und auch,
was wir für Gemeinsamkeiten haben,
obwohl wir nicht miteinander
aufgewachsen sind.
Und ...
Ich erwarte einfach ...
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Susan hat ihren Vater
seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen.
Eigentlich wollte ihre Mutter
sie auf der Reise begleiten,
machte dann aber einen Rückzieher.
Ich stand unter Schock.
Ich habe mich ...
... etwas im Stich gelassen gefühlt.
* Türklingel *
Susan fand schnell
eine neue Begleitung:
Ihre Freundin Monika kommt mit.
Hey.
- Hoi.
Hallo.
Ich mache gerade einen Chai.
- Da komme ich gerade recht.
Behalt die Schuhe doch an.
- Ich habe noch einen Apfelrest.
Ah ja, du weisst ja,
wo der Kompost ist.
Genau.
Super, super.
Die beiden sind Nachbarinnen
und verbringen viel Zeit zusammen.
Susans Vergangenheit ist in
den Gesprächen immer wieder Thema.
Es verbindet uns
die Selbstbetrachtung.
Wir gehen oft
zusammen auf die Burgkapelle.
Geniessen die Sonne und ...
... und besprechen
unsere Herzensangelegenheiten.
Der Vater ...
Die Frage ist:
Was denkt er über mich?
Oder wie steht er zu mir?
Wie fest mag er mich?
Ich glaube, das ist auf eine Art
dein Damoklesschwert.
Was ist mit dem Vater
und seiner Haltung dir gegenüber.
Susan ist 45 und hat ihren Vater
nur selten gesehen.
Es brauchte einen speziellen Anlass.
Die schönsten Erinnerungen hat sie
an die Zeit, als sie zwölf war.
Damals hat sie ihn mit ihrer Mutter
zwei Wochen lang besucht.
Er war Lehrer. Jetzt ist er retired.
Dein Dad?
- Ja, das ist speziell.
Er war Lehrer
für Kinder mit special needs.
Und ich so ...
Ich habe auch special needs.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Mit zwölf fand deine Mutter,
dass ihr nochmals rübergeht.
"Du darfst ihn kennenlernen."
- Als Mensch mit Bewusstsein.
Du mit zwölf
im Vergleich zu eineinhalb.
Mit 24 ist Susan
in die USA ausgewandert,
aber nicht zum Vater an die Ostküste,
sondern nach Kalifornien.
Dort wollte sie sich
als Künstlerin durchschlagen.
Ich wollte schauen,
ob ich mich in meinem Vaterland -
wie ich es nenne,
weil der Vater von dort ist -
durchschlagen kann.
Ob das Klischee stimmt von wegen:
"Du musst einen Brotjob haben."
"Du musst etwas Rechtes haben,
du musst, du musst."
Ich wollte diese Vorsicht-
und Angstkultur unterwandern.
Sie blieb fast vier Jahre
in Kalifornien.
Dort soll ihre Reise auch beginnen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich, wenn
ich von der US-Westküste her komme,
weniger als das kleine Mädchen
zum Vater komme,
sondern eher als gestandener Mensch,
als gemachte Frau.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Morgen geht es in die fremde Heimat -
zuerst nach Kalifornien,
dann an die Ostküste zu ihrem Vater.
Ein neuer Tag in Jerewan.
Gestern zeigte Ando
Giada die Sehenswürdigkeiten.
Heute lernen sie ein anderes Gesicht
der Stadt kennen.
Im Quartier Kond wohnen die Ärmsten.
Es erinnert an die Favelas in Rio.
Ich war zwar noch nie dort,
aber ich sah viele Dokus.
So kommt es mir hier in Jerewan vor.
- Achtung.
Sie sagt, sie wird uns zeigen,
wie das Leben ...
* Er spricht armenisch. *
* Sie spricht armenisch. *
Sie sagt,
Armenien habe sich verändert.
Aber nicht für sie.
Sie beschwert sich nicht.
Sie sagt einfach,
das sei das wahre Leben Jerewans.
* Sie spricht armenisch. *
Sie lebt schon
in sechster Generation hier.
Schon im 19. Jh., also 18...
Sie leben schon seit 1886 hier.
86? Im gleichen ...
1886.
Nicht 1986.
- Oh, wow.
Urgrossvater und, und, und.
Schon in sechster Generation.
WC ...
Das ist das WC.
Ihr Vater hatte zehn Kinder.
Wie ich es verstanden habe,
war er Schuhputzer.
Sie ist sehr gläubig.
Diese Kerzen sind aus Jerusalem,
aus einer armenischen Kirche.
Sie kennt jemanden, der die Kerzen
extra für sie mitgebracht habe.
Sie sagte,
die seien jetzt für uns alle.
Das ist für dich.
- Jöh. Vielen Dank.
Wahnsinn. Ich möchte gerne
noch ein Foto zusammen machen.
Sie ist für mich
ein grosses Vorbild.
Man sagt, die armen Menschen
seien eher bereit, etwas zu geben.
Sie hat nichts.
Sie ist aber bereit,
uns Kerzen zu geben.
Und Früchte.
- Sie wollte uns Früchte geben.
Auch Ando ist in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
Sein Elternhaus
möchte er unbedingt suchen.
Aber vorher liegt ihm
ein anderer Besuch am Herzen.
Für Susan geht die Reise los.
Der Flug von Zürich
nach San Francisco,
an die Westküste der USA,
dauert 12 Std.
Sind Sie frei?
Vier Jahre lang
lebte Susan in Kalifornien.
* Instrumentalversion von "California
Dreamin'" von The Mamas & The Papas *
Damals, Mitte 20, lebte Susan
ein Hippie-Leben mal hier, mal dort.
In dieser Zeit sind enge Freund-
schaften mit Menschen entstanden,
die sie ewig nicht mehr gesehen hat.
Darum beginnt ihre Reise
in die Vergangenheit hier.
Ich bin überwältigt.
Ich bin überwältigt,
wieder in den Staaten zu sein
und in San Francisco,
bzw. in der Nähe davon.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Nach 16 Jahren ist Susan
endlich wieder in ihrer alten Heimat
im Sonnenstaat Kalifornien.
Mir fällt die ganze Anspannung
der Reise
und der Reisevorbereitungen
und alles von den Schultern.
Wegen des Windes
und dem Aufs-Meer-hinausschauen.
Ich vermisse es, dass wir
in der Schweiz kein Meer haben.
Ehrlich.
* Leises Gespräch und Lachen *
Wo gehen wir jetzt hin?
Jetzt gehen wir an die Pine Street
und schauen, ob Bob noch dort wohnt.
Er hat mich
eine Zeit lang aufgenommen,
als ich hier angekommen bin
und versucht habe, Fuss zu fassen.
Ich habe etwas auf Google
recherchiert.
Im besten Fall ist er noch dort,
er lebt, und ist gerade zu Hause
und freut sich,
mich nach so langer Zeit zu sehen.
Ein Überraschungsbesuch spät abends
bei einem Bekannten
nach fast 20 Jahren:
Susan will es versuchen.
Jetzt bin ich leicht verwirrt.
Hier ist doch die Fünf ...
Ah, hier.
Die Klingel sieht kaputt aus.
- Klopfen.
Oh, schau. Es kommt jemand.
As we all are.
Es übertrifft
alle meine Erwartungen.
Zuerst dachte ich eher:
"Hoffentlich ist er nicht zu Hause."
"Er wird zu Tode erschrecken."
Aber er war so offen:
"Hey, wanna come in?"
"Who is this?"
You just say: "Hello, come in."
Auch Vernon
ist ein Freund von damals,
den Susan in all diesen Jahren
aus den Augen verloren hat.
Aber Bob kann helfen.
Ich habe von Bob
diese Nummer bekommen.
So, the 510-number?
Yeah, try that one.
Well, well, well.
Bye.
Bye, Vernon.
Er ist in Oakland.
Er hat morgen früh Zeit.
Ja.
Es war gleich "Hoi!",
als wäre nichts gewesen.
* Instrumentalversion
von "California Dreamin'" *
Bye-bye.
- Bye, Bob.
Bye.
Kaum gelandet hatte Susan
bereits das erste Erfolgserlebnis.
Ganz anders Ando und Giada.
Ihnen steht heute
ein trauriger Besuch bevor.
Ando zeigt seiner Freundin
das tragischste Kapitel
in Armeniens Vergangenheit.
Beim Völkermord
während des Ersten Weltkrieges
haben die türkischen Herrscher
über 1,5 Mio. Christen umgebracht.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich mit meinem Vater hier war.
Du warst schon mal hier?
- Ja.
Ando war sechs,
als er mit seinem Vater
das Denkmal
zu Ehren der Opfer besucht hat.
Sein Vater
ist vor vier Jahren gestorben.
Das ewige Feuer soll dafür sorgen,
dass der Völkermord auch über 100
Jahre später nicht vergessen wird.
* Eindringlicher, hoher Gesang *
Dieser Ort löst bei Ando vieles aus:
Trauer und Betroffenheit,
aber auch schöne Erinnerungen.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das in Worte fassen soll.
Es ist ein tolles Gefühl,
hier zu sein.
Ja ...
Einerseits ist es schön,
andererseits Erinnerungen
an meinen Vater,
an die Zeit, als ich klein war.
Es ist schön, zurück zu sein.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich mich ausdrücken soll.
Es sind schöne Erinnerungen.
Auch an das Respektzollen
an die verstorbenen Armenier.
Ich hatte vorher Gänsehaut.
Ich musste mit den Tränen kämpfen.
Ein schöner Moment.
* Sanfte, dunkle Klänge *
Nächste Woche landet Ando
mitten in seiner Kindheit.
In diesem Haus
wohnte er mit seiner Familie,
bis er mit sieben flüchten musste.
Es gab nichts. Wir hatten nichts.
Es war genau so.
Das ist meine Herkunft.
Und in den USA erwartet Susan
das Wiedersehen mit ihrem Vater.
Ich sehe jemanden. Aber ich glaube,
der ist nicht lang genug.
Nein, das ist nicht Dad.